so we want to be very transparent so as
you know I keep classified everything
they'll be able to see how this hoax how
the hoax or witch-hunt started and why
it started it was a an attempted coup or
an attempted takedown of the President
of the United States I don't know what
it is I have no idea but I want to be
transparent everybody wanted me to be
classify I've done it and you're gonna
learn a lot I hope it's going to be nice
but perhaps it won't be President Trump
on his way to Japan talking about
declassifying intelligence actually
authorizing the Attorney General to
declassify whatever he had to in the
investigation into the investigators the
House Intelligence Committee Chairman
tweeted out while Trump stonewalls the
public from learning the truth about his
obstruction of justice Trump and bar
conspired weaponized law enforcement and
classified information against their
political enemies the cover-up has
entered a new and dangerous phase this
is unamerican with that let's bring in
our panel steve hilton is the host of
the next revolution here on fox news
channel democratic strategist lesley
marshall and ben shapiro syndicated
columnist and editor in chief of the
daily wire he's here there is what do
you think well I mean I think that it's
about time that we got some of the
rumors out of the way I mean the
president has been claiming that there's
been some sort of massive conspiracy
against him from the beginning I think
the more material the public eye the
better I felt that way about the Mulla
report as well so I do have some issues
with Adam Schiff who claimed for years
that there was secret information that
the president was a Russian cat's-paws
suddenly declaring now that manipulation
of intelligence information is
incredibly dangerous that seems like
quite a flip-flop yeah you know the the
cover-up has entered a new and dangerous
phase we hear a lot about the cover-up
I'm wondering what the cover-up actually
constitutes here since we actually can
see the Mullen report in fact it's a
best-seller I mean we can all read it
the the portions that have not been they
have not been released into the public
arena have not been done so for for
because of federal rules of criminal
evidence that prevent that from from
being done I failed to see where the
cover-up is actually occurring and I
guess if it's done them again not
testifying well that's up to DOM again
isn't it I mean he doesn't have
listen to the president if he doesn't
want to but that's not full transparency
I was agreeing with you up until a
couple of sentences ago we when we look
at what we need to have full
transparency and I agree the American
people need to must have full
transparency whether it's with the
Muller report which is three-pronged
including Russia's interference in our
elections but we also have to look at
what has gone on in the past this but
this is not a witch hunt and what
bothers me here is the undermining of
our intelligence officials who you know
out there you know with their sources
and their methods this could be a
problem in the future for people that
they need to have speak to them going
forward for information and also the
perception by many not just on the left
that the Attorney General is attacking
critics of the president and protecting
the president rather than the oath he
took to have his allegiance to the
Constitution to the people of the United
States what's the best point the so the
cover-up is the cover-up of the
obstruction of justice the obstruction
of justice is to obstruct something that
did not find criminal indictment right
yes but you ought to lawyers who were
Republicans who said you know they were
very surprised that nobody went after
him for witness tampering at the end at
the end at the end of the day you have a
foreign government who came to the the
Trump campaign and thankfully they said
look we're not interested that's not a
coup they were doing their job with the
information that they had because it's
three prong and one of the prongs of
that investigation that Muller was
tasked with is to look into the
interference by the Russians this is not
just all about the President and all
about the Trump campaign I you know it's
gonna be interesting Steve when we see
and it could be the Inspector General
report in days
you know maybe weeks but days it'll be
fascinating to see what's in there yes
because letting talked about undermining
the intelligence services there are a
lot of people in this country who are
suspicious that it was the intelligence
services undermining the president and
the candidate that they that they were
supporting and I don't we should not
underestimate the fury of millions of
Americans who see their votes
for Donald Trump scorned on a daily
basis by Democrats who are basically
blocking him from governing with his
endless investigations and they want
equal justice and I think this is a
really important step towards that now
it may turn out that these suspicions of
a deep state coup against the president
it may also be as much of a conspiracy
theory as the Russia collusion story
turned out to be okay probably didn't
follow all elements of it now the big
question is whether Rob Bala is going to
testify and here is the president and
also a gern Adler on that they're asking
Bob Butler to come and testify he just
gave them a 434 page report which says
no collusion which leads to absolutely
no obstruction he just gave that report
why does he have to testify it's
ridiculous Muller he I think I can say
at this point that he wants to testify
in private he envisions himself
correctly as a man of great rectitude
and apolitical and he doesn't want to
participate in anything that he might
regard as a political spectacle yep and
the fact is that Muller is doing the
right thing however I mean look Muller
did put out his report if Muller
believed that the president should have
been indicted the president gave him
every ability to say that so did
attorney general Barr the fact is that
Muller declined to actually issue any
statement on whether obstruction of
justice occurred or did not that was his
decision he could make a man-made
recommendation he did not Democrats have
the same information they can impeach
they're not moving to do so so I'm just
wondering what exactly they're hoping to
financee Pelosi came out this week and
said that more impeachment hearings
wouldn't actually produce any new
information this this just seems like a
lot of political grandstanding debate so
is it Leslie the Democrats wanted
Pietschmann but not the impeachment
process you know they want the hearings
they want the show but they don't really
want to go down the politically
dangerous walk of impeachment it is
politically dangerous look what happened
when Republicans impeached Bill Clinton
Newt Gingrich resigned Republicans lost
seats in the House and the Senate and
speaker Pelosi knows this in addition
when you just look at the polls the
American people don't want this and they
didn't want it
by the way it but but right now you have
approximately 15% of Democrats in the
House and the Senate
combined that are pushing for
impeachment and although it seems like
it's a much larger number and that
Democrats are more split that that is
not the case but what they're trying to
do by having Muller sit there is ask
questions such as so why didn't you push
for obstruction what specifically were
your concerns because you're not talking
about one area you're talking about ten
plus areas where he was questioning but
he did leave that up to the Attorney
General and I don't think it's wrong
with their oversight responsibility
constitutionally a congressional
oversight of the executive branch to ask
those questions so if they're going to
go through the impeachment process they
have every single eye dotted in t cross
but the danger is that Republicans would
also be asking why didn't you look into
that what the government did at the
beginning of the process
absolutely Denis look into the original
start of the investigation absolutely
which is why I would think that
Republicans would be you know walking
hand in hand if you will with Democrats
saying we want him to sit down as well
because we have questions we want it
last thing Steve this back and forth
with the President and Nancy Pelosi now
you have tweeted videos now you have
back-and-forth about somebody's got a
check whether there's an intervention
needed you know what do we take from
this well I think most people look at
that and just just despair they think
their whole thing is this pantomime the
but you know we've got to be clear about
who's driving us I mean if you look at
the anatomy of what happened this week
I think it's very evident that Nancy
Pelosi insulted the president calling
all these accusations of a Watergate
style cover-up before an important
meeting that they claimed were they were
in favor of I think she's a completely
disingenuous charlatan over this I think
it's ridiculous to try and pretend that
they're doing anything other than trying
to block this president from achieving
anything at all well I just have to just
your face okay first of all my insiders
on the left talking to me one of them
there wasn't a plan to have too rushed
meetings you know to talk about
impeachment until you know the president
said we can't testify
they said it's up to him and he said I'm
not going to testify and they were
panicking and that happened to be before
the infrastructure meeting I know you
you know yes we could be clever but that
wasn't like a clever coup if you will
you know we see people politicians left
to right the president included insult
each other all the time he's the
President of the United States he needs
to have a thicker skin I'm sorry she
said what she felt and is that going the
sentiments of a lot of people not only
in the party but that put her in the
position to be Speaker 10 this president
with this Congress get anything done
before the 2020 election no okay